you know I love you Madison I love you
okay you were on Celebrity drag race
with me you got to go out there and drag
a ball
do you remember what your drag name was
on our show oral fixation I'll never
forget
experience like I
asked it wasn't I mean being a fan of
drag race for 10 plus years has been
like
it's my dream yeah um so it was it was
incredible it was the coolest thing I've
ever done maybe yeah I'll always be the
biggest fan well I have seen every one
of your videos okay I'm such a fan of
you you know this I but I know that you
are also a super fan of pop culture and
that you at one point had a Rihanna fan
page that you ran anonymously is this
true I will never live this down I know
this will follow me to the Grave yes I
did I did did you ever meet her I did I
met her like a year ago at one of her
Fenty events and it was I was just
embarrassing what did you say
okay so okay thank you thank you thank
you it was I have this thing where
anyone who I love and I'm obsessed with
I just word vomit things that I'm like
why would you ever say that like that's
just embarrassing and like so stupid I
think Rihanna was was like okay girl but
so we were having not even a
conversation first of all I was at her
event and there's of course everyone's
trying to take a photo with her and I
don't even want a picture I just want to
I don't even want to be in her presence
I'm too like afraid but I of course do
want to be so her assistant was like
it's your turn and my friend's taking a
video and you could literally see in the
video she's this close to me but her
assistant is here and I'm like I'm not
ready I can't do this and I'm completely
terrified and she's like no come on like
go cause you could say hi yeah and she's
like oh hey and I'm like hi and she's
like Madison I'm like I could not
believe she knew my existence it was
pretty shocking to me and then we hugged
took a photo very quick one and then as
I'm walking away I was like Pisces Queen
Queen
[Applause]
what are we
mentioned comments what's happening but
I said that to Rihanna I was like Pisces
queen and I I just like wouldn't say
that in like passing that is so fun and
cool and I just applaud you for being
you I applaud you for telling your
truths and I can see
you're objectively like the good that
you will do with this amazing book thank
you that you wrote
[Applause]
um
the half of it is available now and
everybody here we make this show for you
so just take it with you
[Music]
foreign